DNA that's the crinkly colorful strand  forms loops that bring certain genes  around and into contact with the piece  of DNA that regulates them that flips  the switch turning those jeans on here's  how it happens a two-part protein  complex that's the yellow figure eight  forms around the DNA the loops slide in  opposite directions and push out another  loop the new loop expands until each  side hits a stop signal bat-signal acts  as the landing site for a protein called  ctcf those stop signs become the loop  anchors and the anchored loop becomes a  domain inside it the genes and other DNA  have a much higher chance of interacting  than when they were not part of the loop